[Music]
When The War started
they've protected me
took better care of me than humans sort
of
and our people Maya
it's programming
ten years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
this is a fight for our very existence
Taylor will
[Applause]
the AI are developing a super weapon
retrieve it
he went
did you locate the weapon yeah it's just
a kid
no you're gonna be a good person to go
to heaven so we're the same we can't go
to heaven cause you're not good
and I'm not a person
she looks like a little girl now but
she's growing
Whoever has that kid wins the war
[Applause]
what do you want sweetie are robots to
be free
oh we don't have that in the fridge how
about ice cream
[Music]